If you've never seen
a Monsterverse movie...
If you don't know what
the excitement's all about...
Oh my God.
Hoo-ah!
If you've been hoping to
finally get in on the action...
This is what we've been looking for.
Check this out.
A few things you should
know before going in:
First,
you don't need to know
anything before going in.
What?
What do you mean?
The, uh, what's going on?
Nothing?
Nothing.
Nothing!
What's Monarch?
I don't know.
What about all the monsters?
What about the monsters?
Oh my God!
What if you don't
know much about Godzilla
or monsters in general?
The thing is,
you actually do.
Trust me, come on.
From cave drawings
to mythological characters
around the world,
we've been telling each
other wild monster myths since...
since...
since...forever.
And these guys just
happen to be the latest
in that very long tradition.
And here's the other thing:
This isn't a monster story.
What are you playing at here?
I know we just went through
a whole thing about monsters,
but our show really is-
a people story.
And the things we dig
into are very human.
It is your family business.
It's not our family business,
it's the family curse.
And it happens to have
a few monsters in it.
Because at the end
of the day, this show-
is fun.
Like, really fun.
Move!
So just sit back,
relax,
and enjoy.